You may think that something as small as being optimistic won't change much about your life.
Have you ever heard this line?
"Just because I'm paranoid doesn't mean the world isn't out to get me."
Now that may be a joke, but many people believe the deck is stacked against them.
People who are reverse paranoids, otherwise known as optimists,...
...use the same consistent thinking, but they believe that the world is plotting to do them good.
Everything that happens is pushing them in the right direction.
This attitude breeds more good thoughts,...
...so why not practice to become a reverse paranoid?
Start seeing obstacles as opportunities to grow and change.
When your presentation doesn't get the sale, see it as an opportunity...
...to create a better presentation and become better at your job.
See the task that gives you some power to change rather than the fear that makes you feel powerless.
Look for the seed of something better when everything is going wrong.
Almost everyone sees getting laid off as a bad thing,...
...but even if you want your job to be over, the end always feels sad and uninspiring.
The end of one job, however, always holds the promise of the new beginning of the next job.
If you look at it that way, you're focusing on what a reverse paranoid thinks about.
Identify the great benefit in every event.
Soon, you'll start to see that good is not an accident but something you create with your attitudes.